hey guys it is the 24th of June my name
is Jess McDonald and we're getting back
into the swing of things with our first
GS news episode back from e3 we hope you
missed us we certainly missed you and
now let's talk about video games
launching broken yeah at least some
things don't change Batman Arkham Knight
may have racked up a number of favorable
review scores but some aspects of the
game have been going really really wrong
first up the PC version of the game has
exhibited problems in its compatibility
with AMD GPU cards resulting in
significant bugs glitches and various
other performance issues today publisher
Warner Brothers have suggested that
gamers lower their game settings to help
deal with the current issues as they're
being resolved as you can imagine PC
gamers don't love being told to tone
down their settings to allow a poorly
optimized and buggy game to run properly
you can check out the minimum and
recommended specs that Warner Brothers
has provided gamers in our story on
gamespot as if that wasn't bad enough
the official guide for the game has a
pretty blatant typo not in the fine
print all the blurb on the back button
within the actual name of the game there
may be no I in team but as far as the
copy editors for the official batman
arkham knight guide are concerned there
also appears to be no I night I'll sure
how that one slipped past them next up
the fallout 4 special edition is in
stock in various places but numbers are
super limited if you miss out on the
first batch of special editions which
sold like hotcakes as soon as Bethesda
announced they were available for
pre-order it sounds like you'll still
want to get a move on if you've got your
eye on that awesome real life Pip Boy
well and the game I guess the pip-boy
edition is available for pre-order at
best buy walmart and gamestop and while
it's currently classified as unavailable
on amazon bethesda have said that more
units will be made available there later
in the week finally if you love destiny
then I hope
like Red Bull since early access to one
quest and an XP boost will only be
available by entering a code found on
certain cans of the energy drink that's
right the FPS game a stereotype is
strong with this promotion activision
announced the partnership today
explaining that the quest is said to be
a multi-stage mission in the taken king
and the XP boost amounts to fifty
percent for 30 minutes after the code is
redeemed if you're into the idea the
cans will be sold throughout July in
7-eleven stores if you're not into the
idea then the quest will be available
for everyone on january one of next year
and you probably enjoy the satirical
sentiments of dying light dev Techland
who responded with their own parody
promotion offering a code for a premium
weapon docket to players who post a
picture of themselves drinking water
with the hashtag drink right dying light
the dev told Twitter their quote jumping
on the latest trend in game marketing
well played Techland let me know down in
the comments what you think of the
deaths in the promotion and whether or
not you've already pre-ordered fallout 4
you can add your gamespot we've got
stories on the free PS Plus edition of
driveclub and new details on recall
that's everything I've got for you today
as always let me know what mattered to
you and I'll be back same time tomorrow
with a bunch more news
you